boo I don't know what to say this is you
know I love candy canes frankly I eat a
candy cane every day the candy canes I
like the best of the big thick one
appetizers I'll take the candy cane and
pop a little bite in and then keep my
breath back all right bring on your dawn
just then let's make these things so
hard to open it's not as minty as I'm
accustomed to got coffee flavor to it
it's not horrible
burnt popcorn with butter bacon oh my
goodness I guess I have to try it again
we'll put bacon knowledge it tastes
somewhere not coffee
particularly careful bacon in his candy
more crunch you know that oh my goodness
well it's not - oh my goodness it's got
hot spicy - it kind of birth this letter
gets burners I do pizza BBQ sauce hot
sauce wine sabi sriracha sauce it wakes
you up a little bit I play eat this
little piece but it's just wasn't what I
was expecting it does not have the
center is your neck wha it's not
terrible I'm drawing a complete blank
there's nothing here it's not minty it
had had a mint flavors it's a regular
candy cane once a zit lettuce or celery
is a pickle didn't taste the brine
didn't taste the pickle now I'm starting
to get the pickle flavor they're
stretching that one a bit all right come
on open up you know that I want to know
what this one is really what the heck is
that
that one's different it has quite a kick
to it
glad the stripes are browned that green
stuff I get that Japanese restaurant is
that one sabi yeah no thank you
yeah Sansa like the one with the
Vietnamese hot spice I kind of like it
the bacon one tasted really good the
wasabi not so much the one sabi yes